mm go read but it's pretty fat and I got
something awesome in my hand not you
I got a PlayStation 4 and I tweeted a
latte and your brother said you should
play with a flame you should play with a
playroom you should play with a brick so
guess what I'm gonna play with your eyes
so we're in the PlayStation you ready to
get your mind blown
so what you want to do is you want to
tickle it I like to take it with my
tongue I'll take it with my hand why
does it never work when I try to do
stuff with it
oh so meet the AR box a box butts god
damn it
okay so now the boxes
I mean God says there in here is shaking
it feels good so you want you wanna
anyway okay okay I like I flip them up
you know [ __ ] what up you want a friend
I'll give you two three three friends
five frame I'm not hurting man like that
happening no they're like explaining or
something okay maybe morning they're
scared of the duck of course you can
touch him I think
yeah well come here
come on you can worry about them too in
there like yeah yeah way bad man you can
like bounce it this is the I don't wanna
need your heart yeah yeah come back oh
yeah they're inside now if you suck this
guy in that sounds weird okay and then
you can there's an easter egg if you
like so you can see inside the
controller sorry sorry yeah you can like
click on the control you see that and
this becomes a party and then dumpster
they never go what I want to go this is
like when you do on there and on strip
clubs with money you how do you know
I hope so ah y'all gonna die tonight I
don't think you can but I'm a tiny head
I'm pulling up inside I want to I don't
give him the deck Doc's are terrifying
everyone knows what are you gonna do
with the deck but you're really
perverted yeah a good point a Mack [ __ ]
it's kind of cold having us
all right Prez that's all over the plate
room and they sent me a ton of games for
the PlayStation 4 I got I got Killzone I
got this it's pretty more than anything
I'm excited for watchdogs honestly but
still plays a [ __ ] for it seems pretty
cool let me know what you think about it
look like I mean your question it's the
sky over today
see Bros into next 1000 love you didn't
think I was gonna brofist did you hear
that
that's it I don't know when I even try
at